let's just focus on what's real and
what's happening okay so what's real
is scott disick just posted the sweetest
message to his ex kourtney kardashian on
instagram
and what's happening is our hearts are
melting
i love it on monday the 37 year old
reality star posted
this family pic that's court and scott
with
two of their three kiddos six-year-old
reign and
eight-year-old penelope the caption
quote thank you courtney for being the
best baby maker in town
i couldn't have asked for a better
person in the world to have these
amazing children with
i love you and our family more than
anything in the world
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
you want to be comfortable the touching
message came shortly after scott penned
two cute insta tributes on his son's
shared birthdays
yes they both were born on december 14th
first for his oldest son mason who
turned 11
then for rayne he captioned this
daddy-son pick with mace in part
quote you have made my life such a
better life
thank you and i love you and for his
youngest son
he echoed that sentiment writing quote
next up
my little angel reign you have also made
my life so much better and i thank you
and love you court and scott ended their
nine-year relationship
in 2015 but have crushed it when it
comes to co-parenting together it's hard
work for all parties i'm really proud of
all of them
when e.t caught up with scott and khloe
kardashian back in 2019
she applauded them for the way they make
it work i think they're
doing amazing and i think everyone has
to handle their co-parenting situation
in their own style but
my mom and my dad were like that it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be and
love is love and i'm so proud of them
and i'm so proud of them promoting that
and hopefully
you know inspiring other people that
it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that and while court and scott have the
whole co-parenting thing down
pat a source told et last month that we
shouldn't expect them to get back
together
quote they have a good thing going and
it works perfectly for their family
as for scott he's been getting close
with amelia gray hamlin
you know lisa arena and harry hamlin's
19 year old daughter
the two have been spotted together a
bunch lately and on thanksgiving the
model included scott in an insta-story
post about the people she was thankful
for
so what does court think of the whole
amelia thing well
our source says she isn't fazed courtney
isn't bothered that scott is hanging out
with emilia gray hamlin and is so far
past
thinking about him in a romantic way she
knows scott better than
anybody and she is supportive
[Music]